so leute ich habe gute nachrichten für
euch ihr braucht den info text nicht zu
lesen ihr müsst nicht kreativ sein ihr
müsst keine video antwort aufnehmen all
das entfällt weil wir machen wegen des
großen erfolges einmal wieder die
umfrageaktion wer soll unser nächster
gast bei pixum seien auf facebook link
ist unten im info text also verteilen
müssen schon mal reingucken aber ganz
oben einfach nur drauf klicken und dann
gebt eure stimme stimmen abschlag selber
gäste vor und haut rein und dann
versuche ich den gast zu kriegen man es
mal geklappt mit haftbefehl mal sehen
wer dieses mal rauskommt ich sag mal
präsident obama könnte ein wenig
schwierig sein es dauert dann einfach
nur länger bis er endlich kommt aber ich
werde mich bemühen ihn auf jeden fall
oder sie einzuladen zu klicks um also
haut rein ich bin gespannt auf den
ausgang der jetzt aktuellen um viel spaß